We mentioned that the greedy approach of constructing
a DHT leads to tree saturation. And the
congestion happens at the node, which happens to
map to a lot of clustered keys. The coral
approach is very simple, don't be greedy. What
does that mean well what it mean the
greedy approach,when we have a key K, we try to store it in the lower N who's
note i.d is equal to K the coral approach
use this as a hint not and absolute. But you
still have to have a method to the madness, if
you're going to store it in some place different from N.
Then, those who are trying to discover it, have to
have a method to the madness, of where you stored
your key. We'll see how that is done. So the
top level bit I want you to take away is
that in the Coral DHT The get and put operations are satisfied by nodes that are
different from the key K. The node IDN may not be close to key, and
that's why the DHT that Coral implements is
called a sloppy DHT, and we'll talk about
details of that in a minute. The rationale
of course, is you want to avoid tree saturation,
that comes about when lot of keys map to a particular node ID. And also in
the process, what we want to do is, spread
the metadata overload so that no single node
in this democratic process of helping one another
is saturated or overloaded by being a good
citizen. How does Coral do it? It has
a novel key-based routing algorithm, which we'll describe,
but the basis for that key-based routing algorithm is to compute the distance
between, the source of a get or a put operation and the destination for that
get or put operation. The destination by default is going to be the node
whose ID is equal to the key that you're looking for. So the distance between
the source and the destination is X or distance, meaning [UNKNOWN] or
the bit pattern Of the node ID for the source and the bit pattern for
the node ID for the destination that X or of the two qualities give
you the distance between the two nodes in the
overlay network space. And the reason why you want to do an XOR
is because an XOR operation as opposed to,
say, doing a subtraction, is going to be much
faster. We do an XOR to find out
the distance between the source and the destination that
need to communicate. So, for instance, if the
source at, this is fourteen, and the destination address
is four. Remember that these are null IDs
in the null ID space which at the level
of the user. And if you do an X sort of that you get 10, so
10 is the distance between the source 14
and,and the destination for. The bigger the XOR
value, the larger the distance between the source
and the destination in the application namespace. And
since we are dealing with fairly big numbers
here, the node ID could be 160 bit quantity.
And that is the reason we want to use
some simple operation that will get us the distance.
X R is a very quick operation to
implement to get the distance between source and destination.